[Music]
mine well thank you everyone for coming
out today I'm miles Barnes I'm and
developer advocate on cloud platform
also one of the main Tanner's of nodejs
and do a lot of work with product
managers like Jason who's doing really
amazing stuff will tell you all about it
right now I'm Jason I'm a product
manager on clouds specifically in the
service space before we dive in and I
just want to make sure that we make it
clear that service can mean many many
things in cloud platform it's not just
computers many services that we have
that are service in the sense that you
don't manage infrastructure and you
paper usage for the purpose of this talk
we're really narrowly scoping that just
to compute and concretely in cloud
platform that means two products cloud
functions and app engine for those
unfamiliar cloud functions is our event
driven service compute platform you
deploy functions and they execute in the
cloud and App Engine is the og service
from cloud platform web applications
again sort of totally sail or scales to
zero so with App Engine yes so quick
pull the audience how many people in the
audience have used App Engine before
awesome
and how many people have been using it
for more than five years that's really
amazing
App Engine celebrated his ten-year
anniversary this year it's pretty
exciting that we've had it as long as we
have and just a quick recap of all the
things it was launched in i/o in May of
2018 originally a Python runtime with a
memcache API introduced up Java Runtime
in April of 2009 and App Engine moved at
a preview in 2011 we introduced a go
runtime in 2012 a PHP runtime in 2013
Java 8 last year in June and most
recently at i/o with starin over here we
introduced
the world to know GS 8 on App Engine
standard on our new second-generation
runtime so our new second-generation
runtime is open source idiomatic
experience you write code the same way
for App Engine that you would to just
run on any version of the runtime
rewriting if you know how to write
Python to run it on your computer you
know how to write Python to run on an
app engine the new second-generation
runtime can use any extension or binary
or framework if you're writing node
pretty much any node module that you
want to use you can use any you know
Java library or Python library the
things that are running on the second
generation can run them and this is a
big difference from the first generation
runtime and as I mentioned node 8 we
announced at i/o but today we wanted to
let you know about two new runtimes
which are Python 37 and PHP 7 to which
you can use on App Engine today which is
really exciting so on the cloud
functions side again a quick recap we we
went beta launch at this event last year
in March and we launched two beta with a
node.js runtime we had some cool
features like HTTP invocation in the box
so you could just deploy a function and
call it directly wire HTTP without any
other any other services required we did
things like stackdriver integration and
of course it's a service product so you
only pay when your code runs and in the
time between then and now we've been
doing a lot of work on adding
capabilities to the platform improving
the performance and and across the board
and so I want to take you through some
of the things that we've been we've been
working on so probably the most
important and upfront is that we are now
generally available so Clara functions
is out of beta thanks
it's open to all it's ready for
production use and we even have an SLA
so we're sort of standing by the
availability we're rolling out to more
regions in beta were only available in
the US in one region us Central we're
now available in four regions too in the
US and one in Europe and one in Asia
we'll be rolling out more regions
progressively but those are available
today and an interesting feature of
cloud functions is that with these new
regions what may not be obvious is that
you can actually deploy different
functions in the same project that are
in different regions this is allows you
to have different capabilities that in
the same project so all the same
permission models the same IM rock rolls
and so on but addressing customers that
may be in particular regions you can
also do things like have functions with
the same name in different regions in
the same project so we mentioned the new
runtimes for App Engine but there's also
some runtime announcements for us to
make for cloud functions first of all I
know I'm really excited about no date
for cloud functions so you can now as of
today write cloud functions using node
8.11 which brings in support for
async/await
for myself that was a major change to
the way in which I wrote JavaScript
thought about asynchronicity
it also has a new function signature
which we'll be showing you in a minute
if you want to deploy you use the
runtime no GS 8 or if you're doing it
through the UI it's available through
the drop down menu so if you're writing
functions today with note 6 you may
recognize this this is what you would
have for a background function where the
the top one is a function written with a
callback and the second one is a
function that's able to return a promise
the API has changed a little bit for
notate where you could see we now have a
data and a context as opposed to an
event previously you would have to dig
into the event to get all this
information this is just available for
you it's a lot faster you can provide
async functions
as the function itself which allows you
to then use the awake keyword to await
the results of asynchronous operations
so as we can see in in this async
function that we have here at the top
for a Hello pub/sub we can do a whole
bunch of asynchronous stuff and if we
had multiple of these asynchronous
operations in a row we would actually be
able to do those in a linear pattern
which is for myself a much better mental
model below we can see the function
signature for HTTP functions which
remains unchanged the main difference
being again you can provide async
functions and use the awake keyword
within it so Python 37 is really
exciting as a new runtime you can write
your cloud functions using Python you
deploy using runtime Python 3:7 here's
an example of HTTP and a pub/sub
function you get a data and a context
for a pub/sub function and a request for
a hello HTTP this is based on flask I
don't know just a lot of people here use
flask cool yeah like is really nice
minimal idiomatic Python way of writing
HTTP servers you can do get put post
delete options the requests themselves
are based on flash start request so if
you know the API signature of that you
already know how to get up and running
and if you don't the docs are there and
the response is just need to be
compatible with flask make response and
you'll be able to start getting
functions up and running with Python
today Python back to background
functions so as with node you get the
data which in Python is addicting you
get a context which is Google Cloud
functions context and that context
there's a whole bunch of information
that you could dig in if to signal that
the function is successful in Python all
you need to do is return from your
function and if there's any problems you
raise an exception and stack driver
error handling will get automatically
notified and you'll be able to do you
know whatever you want to setup in the
process to handle error recovery so
there are common features between both
of these you you have logs so if you log
out using the standard ways of logging
in both libraries those are going to be
sucked up by stack driver and ready for
you to dig in if you've ever used the UI
for deploying functions if you've done
it with node where you
can just kind of click immediately after
running a test and see the logs to see
if it worked is the exact same way you
can do it with Python uncaught
exceptions as I mentioned before are
automatically hands it off to stack
driver logging and stack driver error
reporting and similarly to node Python
also will automatically do the
installation of all of your dependencies
for node you have package.json for
Python you have a requirements txt so
just list your requirements and the
requirements txt and we're going to
install all your dependencies for you in
the cloud so the context object that I
mentioned before this is how it breaks
down you have the event ID the timestamp
the event type and the resource these
will be primarily these will be only for
background functions you don't get a
context object with HTTP functions for
those you get a request in a response in
node and you get the request for Python
but these are the options that you would
have from a background function and you
can use this in your code to determine
like you know was it pub/sub that
triggered me or am I being triggered by
another event that everything is in
there that you need to kind of
understand the context of the object and
where it's running this is an example of
what that may look like this would be
for a publish event on a pub sub-q and
you can get all the way down to even
like the version of pub sub if you're
breaking down that string in the type so
a lot of information in context that you
can get from this for those of you who
are using firebase functions cloud
functions for firebase is now also in GA
and it has full support for no date so
you can write your Xmas script 2017 you
can use async await the language
features that are supported by GCF also
supported by firebase functions there's
a new runtime configuration options that
allow you to control your region and
your memory and timeout
these are really great granular controls
and you know a great thing to dig into
for the productivity of your
applications one of the really cool
things that's coming with this launch 2
is that firebase events for analytics
file store real-time DB and
authentication are now available
directly in cloud functions so you can
use your firebase events to trigger your
your cloud functions both of these
different products have different great
ways of using them and now you can kind
of depending on what you're doing with
your
academic decisions based on what works
best for your team Thanks
so yeah one of the things that we talked
about before in the new runtimes for App
Engine this applies to that as well
we're rebasing the underlying operating
system on Ubuntu and one of the main
reasons for doing this is our ability to
provide system libraries and native
binaries in the image in in cloud
functions historically we've really only
just allowed one and that's image magic
with this switch to a bun - we're really
broadening the scope I've listed a
couple there image magic ffmpeg this is
something a lot of people have asked for
for video processing and we've also made
sure that we've bundled in all the
system libraries required to run
headless Chrome so you can take
screenshots of a web page from within a
cloud function and if you want the big
list here is the list as of a few weeks
ago it may have been actually added to
since then I won't spend too much time
on that another feature that a lot of
customers have asked for is environment
variables so we're announcing today that
you can now specify key value pairs that
are bound to a single function but they
don't exist inside your source code you
set them at deploy time just any
arbitrary number of key value pairs and
then those will be injected as literal
environment variables at execution time
so at deploy time we'll save those and
that at execution time will inject those
into the environment and this is
available in the web UI the cloud
console you can just set them in there
it's also available in the API and the
CLI you saw just before okay miles
demo yeah so all the things we just
talked about I decided hey like let's
make something silly that uses all of
them all at once so I can show you some
things onstage so I've got a demo here
on my machine that I'm going to show you
and so we got here the math bot it's
really friendly nice person I'm going to
start a new conversation with the math
bot and I'll just be like you know like
hey math wha
what's one plus one and you know math
bot needs to think it's been sleeping so
if you're not familiar with scale to
zero when you're not using your
functions they're not running so you're
not paying for it it also means that you
have what's known as a cold boot so the
first time that you do something it's
going to take a second for it to spin up
and figure everything out and get
running hey math bot maybe I shouldn't
have picked something so hard oh I know
why cuz I didn't at math bot didn't know
I was talking to it and this is actually
a really great feature for hangouts chat
so if you're making BOTS they're not
just going to be responding to anything
that you're saying inside of the chat
they're only going to actually respond
when you talk to them
we've got tutorials available online so
you can follow and get your own hangout
spots going and so we could see math
BOTS got back to me pretty quickly I get
to feel like you know like what spy and
it's gonna be like you know it's not
gonna say anything smarmy it's gonna be
pretty quick on that and I can while I'm
waiting for that you know I anything if
you don't address it yeah oh yeah I keep
doing that so you know what I'm just
gonna go to math wat right here I'll be
like what spy and it'll say you know
hopefully 3.14 I could be like what's
the meaning of life and of course it's
gonna come back it's navigating the
Wi-Fi it's it's getting really esoteric
with me but so well we've got going on
here are two cloud functions we've got a
node.js cloud function and a Python
cloud function doing two separate things
so I have my own expertise and one of
them is not machine learning I know node
really well so when I wanted to start
instrumenting with the hangouts chat API
and I needed to do things I haven't done
before it was it was way more idiomatic
and straightforward for me to get
started with nodes so I used node to
create a big a bridge between hangouts
chat and cloud functions but I don't
know anything about writing chat BOTS
but I was googling around and found this
thing called chatter bot which is
available on pip which had a demo that
worked right out of the box so I was
able to get a chat bot spun up with
Python so if we take a look here we
could see here's a here's the hangout
spot here's
source code for the node side of things
and we're using node fetch from big fan
of fetch fetches an API for making
Network requests that returns a promise
we've got this function which is an
async function to ask the bot which
makes the body sets up the headers it
does a try-catch where it goes and waits
for the response of from the bot URL
this is as we can see up here an
environment variable that we've injected
inside of the function and we await for
the response text which is resolving the
result of that and the rest of this is
you know we this is the function that
we're handing out to hangouts chat it's
just saying hey grab the message and ask
the bot and then asking the bot is
heading over here to the Python code
which we can see which is about 41 lines
of code and it's mostly just
instantiation code where I've set up two
logic adapters one of them is custom so
I can make that joke about the meaning
of life that failed and then the other
one is the mathematics evaluation in
there and it was pretty straightforward
to tie the two together if we take a
look here back in the code and we click
Edit we can quickly take a look at the
environment variables that we've got
down here and we can see that I've got
the bot URL right here and that's just
the URL of the other function that I'm
gonna call so I didn't need to embed
that right in if I change the background
function there I can quickly get that
going later but what we've seen here is
a combination of using node for what
nodes good for using Python for what's
pythons good for and using environment
variables to make things a little bit
more flexible and then all of this plugs
into hangouts chat so that you know I
don't need to calculate how many grams
of coffee to use when I'm doing my 1 to
13 ratio of pour over I can just ask map
math bot and it can get snarky with me
but so that's the end of this demo we
can head back to the slide deck now and
I think it's back to you Jason I think
so Thanks
yeah so we'll just keep on rolling with
the news the new things that we're
adding for those people out there who
have used cloud sequel you may have
bumped into this problem that we had
with cloud functions where it was pretty
difficult to talk to cloud sequel
without doing a u-turn out to the
Internet and back so we fixed that you
now have a direct connection to cloud
sequel you just use this socket path
that you can see there slash cloud
sequel /foo is just the name of my
database there and this would be this
would just be in your node code in this
case it's JavaScript there's a little
weird thing there you may have picked up
on this is creating a connection pool of
size 1 why do I need a pool if it's only
1 and that's really a side effect of the
fact that it's a service environment
that's going to scale up and down from
from 0 and up down up to some number and
then back to 0 and so if you're scaling
up rapidly and and I'll talk a little
bit more about this in you know in a
minute
you might overwhelm your database if
each function is creating 10 database
connections and we we do the magic of
scaling it up for you and suddenly you
dose your own database so we recommend a
connection size of 1 but we recommend
you use a pool because it has some nice
features like Auto reestablishing your
connection if it fails so this was the
previous world we would ask customers to
do this horrendous you turn out to the
Internet and use SSL to secure it and so
on well no more of that now you can just
go straight across and that's a secure
connection managed by us as I was just
talking before scaling controls is a new
thing we're adding this is exactly the
scenario I just described you have some
nice evenly shaped traffic
notwithstanding the fact that my diagram
is not even traffic's coming in the
database is happy everyone's happy you
get some more traffic and we do a great
job of scaling up for you but then of
course your database is overloaded and
you can't deal with any more traffic so
what do you do in this situation
well we're introducing scaling controls
so you can actually
limit the number of instances that your
function is going to use why would you
want to do that why would you want to
limit the traffic well the the simple
sort of canonical example is let's say
you have one database and two functions
and one function is your really
important production function that you
don't want to go down maybe it's what
your mobile clients are calling and
that's the important one and then maybe
you have some other background function
or some other analytics or reporting
thing that it doesn't really matter if
it doesn't succeed and maybe it has a
bug and it gets into a loop and it
causes us to scale up many instances of
this non important function and it
causes the database to go down which
causes your really important function to
cease operating so in this case you
would put scaling controls over that
less important function to preserve the
database to make sure that the traffic
is prioritized for the more important
one I'm sorry yes yes or you could use
API throttling the question the comment
was or if there's the throttling limit
in the API yes that would also be
appropriate so the limits are per
function default limit of up to a
thousand and then you can change it on /
function basis so this is what it looks
like with the scaling control same sort
of situation regular traffic coming in
but now new traffic that the gray
vertical line is representing the
boundary of your scaling limit that
you've said well I don't want to scale
beyond this limit so those those boxes
with the dotted line will not be created
and your database stays happy so for
myself I've wanted scheduling for a
really long time I know that all of you
but we're really excited to talk today
about cloud scheduler and cloud
scheduler allows you to schedule HTTP or
pub/sub tasks at variables starting down
to one minute intervals it can invoke
cloud functions over HTTP or over
pub/sub and it can also invoke App
Engine on a rel
to the URL so this means that we can
start setting up timers for events that
we want it to happen it is you know like
setting up cron jobs if you have tasks
that need to happen at a certain
interval this is the way in which you
can set it up so first we're going to
take a look at how that looks for cloud
functions you create a scheduler job you
name that job you have a message body
which is what the body of the message
will be when it's triggered and you
schedule it you can do that using you
know just an English like grammar so you
say everyone minutes you specify the URL
that it's going to trigger and the HTTP
method that is going to use to trigger
it so now this endpoint is going to get
triggered every single minute with post
so if you have things that you need to
do like you know checking an endpoint or
checking like doing anything by a batch
job you can schedule it this way for App
Engine it's a little bit different
you'll notice the two biggest
differences or the relative URL in the
service so with App Engine you can
specify the specific relative URL to the
service that you're going to be
triggering and you can specify the
service because with App Engine you can
deploy multiple services to the same
project so you don't necessarily want to
be triggering the default service I
believe that the relative URL is the
only or no the schedule is probably the
only thing that's mandatory but you can
go through the docs and take a look and
see exactly how you got to spin this up
but it's really great it's intuitive and
I really love this capability and I
think it expands a lot of the things
that we can build with our service
offerings right now we're gonna bring
Deema up on stage quick round of
applause for Deema and just don't worry
about the fact that it says product
marketing everyone at Google writes code
thanks you some big smiles okay I will
stick to this my hair so hey everyone
I'm Deema
I know lead product marketing for cloud
functions and let me show you a demo
which I built using some of those new
features that Jason and miles have just
discussed I'm actually I need some
slides I can we just please go back to
the slide deck
thank you and so sometimes you have to
rely on Jason on an external system as a
part of your service application
architecture and I chose my sequel
database in this case but that could be
any third party API really so imagine a
scenario when your database goes down
you it could be due to an outage or a
service part of your system scaling out
of proportion and overwhelming your
database so you try to write something
into the database and it fails what's
next so you could you could actually
implement some retry logic and you can
retry things immediately and this could
help you when you are dealing with a
small database delay or small
interaction and connectivity but what if
your database is totally slammed and you
might not what you might not want to and
you have thousands of messages that
failed you might not want it overwhelm
it with additional retries every couple
of few seconds so you could actually in
that case you can save your film
messages to something like pipes up for
example but there's a problem which pops
up it's really fast and your retry logic
will actually trigger right away
possibly still too fast if the database
is down for an extended period of time
and obviously if you relied on the pub
sub you actually would have to recuse
OHS messages if they failed again so
when deal when you deal with an unknown
amount of downtime you might want to
persist those messages into something
like cloud storage so that you can
replay them later on you take your time
processing them so to trigger this retry
logic I'm scheduled you can actually you
know stand up a VM and you can create a
virtual machine and things like Linux
crontab have been around for like 50
years and but we're doing service here
and what if your chrome server goes down
do you have another one watching this is
where cloud scheduler can really help so
let's let's say that action now if again
please go back to the demo slides so
what you're looking at here is front-end
part of this damn
it's built in five days and all it does
it just visualizes messages moving
between different components of the of
the back-end architecture in real time
so what we're going to do first we will
send some load to the HTTP endpoint
which is sitting in front of the
database and all it does it writes some
messages to the my sequel database and I
just click the test button and it sent a
few requests to the base and we should
see and there's obviously a lot it's a
live demo so there's some latency
involved okay there they are we see some
blue and green boxes appear here so the
blue box is the represent messages that
were sent to the database and the green
ones are the corresponding successful
writes so when everything is working as
expected we would expect to see the
equal number of those boxes which is
exactly what we're seeing here now let
me actually go to my project settings
and take the database down to simulate
the out an outage so this is I'm using
cloud sequel just for the purpose of
this demo so what I'll do I'll just go
ahead and restart it and that usually
takes a few moments and while the
database is restarting I'm going back to
the visualizer up and sending a few more
requests to the database so now we
should we see some of the red red boxes
pop up here those represent messages
that failed and as expected because the
database is down so those messages are
saved to the dead letter Q which is
built with pops-up and cloud storage and
they of course have another cloud
function there which I'm not showing for
simplicity all it does it just saves the
messages as they pop up on the pops up
pops up topic so now what we can do we
can go ahead and take a look at the dead
letter Q and also create a cloud
scheduler job to rerun those failed
messages so this is my cloud storage
bucket and that'll work use cloud
storage bucket and sometimes it takes a
moment for the UI to refresh here so I'm
just going to click refresh button and
we can see some of our failed messages
they started to pop up pop up here with
the appropriate time stamps from a
minute or so ago so we took after they
can look at that let's go ahead and
create a cloud scheduler job
I actually pre-populated all the values
just to save time and as you can see all
you need to do here is it's really
simple you just have to name it and I'm
using hello next 18 here as a name set
up frequency such as every Friday
afternoon or as in our case every minute
and also select target in our case the
target is the HTTP endpoint which
replace the failed messages and now also
go ahead and start a timer here to track
approximately how much time we have left
until that cloud scheduled job fires off
and as you can see here in the console
hasn't run yet will in version and it
was really easy to I just wanted to
reiterate it was super easy to create a
scheduled job with cloud scheduler so we
actually accomplished something very
powerful here it was just a few clicks
we now have this code that will run
every minute go to the dead letter Q and
and try to replay failed messages if any
so I'm going to switch back to the Oh
okay so I guess the cloud scheduler job
already triggered so for my initial test
I think it happens on top of every
minute and so that was like an
approximate timer for dramatic effect
but it already triggered and and
actually successfully replayed all of
those failed messages and now just to
double-check I'll go back to the bucket
and refresh it and it should be empty
yes and it is empty as expected so just
switching back to the visualizer app and
as you could see the it through plated
successfully and in the real life
scenario obviously if you if you're
building this for reals and you've had a
lot of failed messages like thousands of
them you could there might be a
situation that when you're dead Laura Q
holds way more messages than you can
actually replay within a minute so that
could be solved by either obviously by
either increasing the time interval or
introducing another cloud storage bucket
to hold messages that are being
processed replayed and the recap I just
talked about this idea of how you can
build a reliable system using some of
the primitives that we have available to
you on GCP today and this pattern can be
especially useful when you are
external systems as a part of your
implementation thank you and back to
Jason miles thanks Tina if we can go
back to slides please oh is it slides Oh
looks the same okay let's just keep
rolling
more on cloud functions access and I am
so we're also very excited to announce V
PC access again if anyone's used cloud
functions before you would have
plausibly bumped into this limitation
consider you have some number of virtual
machines GCE instances in cloud platform
those instances let's say are all on the
same network that's great they can talk
to each other and then you have a cloud
function out here in the wild but it
cannot talk to those virtual machines
for very irrational and complicated
network security reasons good news is
we've fixed that bug so you can now
connect the cloud function via a
connection service to that network a and
and thereby grant access from the
function to any virtual machine on that
network yes so you just simply add the
cloud function to the network and allows
you to egress to transmit bytes from the
function to to the virtual machine very
simple command line at deploy time
connected V PC with the name of the
network and you're done on the side of
security controls something that we get
asked for a lot when we started with
cloud functions when we announced the
beta last year I mentioned before that
one of the features that we wanted to
promote was this ability to deploy a
function and give it an HTTP URL and
curl it straight away and it's very very
good for simplicity and terrible for
security because this HTTP function is
invoked ball effectively globally so
what we're introducing now is I am
controls on the data plane itself
on the invoke of a function we have a
new role called cloud functions invoker
and you can assign it to a particular
user in the in the example above I'm
saying Alice Alice can invoke my
function called hello world and in the
example below that's effectively making
it public we have a a special string in
cloud platform called all users which
effectively says that all users have
invoked permission on my function and
this means you can now deploy a cloud
function that cannot be invoked by
anyone in the outside world and this is
perfect for sort of function to function
invocation use cases so it looks like
this outside traffic from the outside
world comes into our serving stack
there's an iam check which checks does
this request have the appropriate
credentials are those credentials
authentic and if they are the function
receives the request as normal the same
situation applies if one function is
calling another function its
identity will be verified by this I M
check and its role verified to make sure
that it has the appropriate role on that
function okay that is the bulk of the
regular announcements and for those who
were paying attention we had a number so
the N is just representing the number it
doesn't really have a number and that's
because this next bit is not ready yet
this is a this is a sneak peek if anyone
was in the server spotlight earlier you
may have seen something in relation to
this and those who weren't you get to
see it now
so coming very soon is service
containers we talked a little bit before
about these next generation runtimes in
App Engine we talked about some
commonalities in the infrastructure
underneath all of that and and this has
been true actually since day one of
cloud functions we actually accept as an
input into the infrastructure a docker
image and so what we're going to be
doing is exposing that to customers so
you can bring along with you any
pre-built docker image you can use any
base image you like I mentioned before
we default to a bun - if you want alpine
linux bring your app on linux you can
arbitrary system libraries arbitrary
language runtime but everything else is
the same you get the same server less
execution environment you don't manage
any servers you pay only when code is
executing all the other bells and
whistles that you saw before the
scheduling the environment variables
while in variables probably can do
yourself but all the surrounding things
are the same and you and you just bring
your container image and prove that this
is true I want to invite stearin onstage
to give you a demo thanks yes right so
we were brainstorming this demo and why
would you use containers when GCF
provides you node and Python well maybe
you have your own favorite programming
language like go or rust we try them it
works but is that what if we could
actually write a cloud function that
renders a 3d image based on the URL
parameter how cool was that and to do
that if we can switch to the demo screen
to do that actually you wrote a very
small HTTP function let me show you the
code yeah so it's a Python function but
simply it will execute a 3d software to
render an image out of a predefined 3d
model and so this software is not in the
cloud function based image the one that
you get when you use the Python version
of code function to use this software I
had to put it into the image of my
function and to do that I simply wrote
this you know 10 lines of code of that
is literally a docker file so that we
describe what how to be how to build
that container image so first thing to
note is that it starts from the official
Python base image like nothing fancy
here then what I'm doing is I'm
installing a 3d software which is the
C++ module of a
on the moon too and then I'm doing you
know I'm starting my app and exposing
the right port and I'm starting the app
so okay let's deploy dance so the first
step would be to build this you know the
dockerfile and the code into a container
image for the sake of time I already did
that if I wanted to do it I would have
used darker build build or I could have
used a cloud build that that builds that
for you in the cloud but this image has
already been built
now I'm just going to deploy it to cloud
functions click load entrance deploy you
know that part the new thing is - -
image and then I point to my container
image that I stored in Google Cloud
registry looks good
here we are we are deploying the image
to flood function so it should take
around around 30 minutes alright so as
you see I could have used any
programming language I want as long as I
can build it into a container image I
could have used any OS package I want as
long as it's available in my in my image
or even I could bring my own binary we
have customers who have special binaries
that they need to import into the upload
function so that's why they do they use
containers to do that here we have it so
let's click on it right so as I told you
this this function takes a URL parameter
which is the location because as we know
we have many cloud necks coming so today
we are in San Francisco and what's
happening here it's that the 3d software
is rendering an image based on the input
I give so you know the next one is in
Tokyo I think and we have London so
quite quite nice
of course I also
all right I added all the three mothers
for fun it's okay yeah in the shooing
this money all right thanks
that's a 3d server error right there
that's container on Google Cloud
functions you can sign up on geo /
service containers to get access to it
thank you okay
that's basically the end just to recap
we've talked about a lot of things many
of them are available today
yeah I'm sure many of you are going to
go out there immediately and start
writing Python cloud functions Python is
available today no date is available
today some of these other features are
rolling out over the next couple of
weeks
just check the cloud platform blog will
be having blog posts coming out over the
next few weeks with instructions on how
to get them and if they're in early
access mode then how you can sign up
thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
you